it's going to be a big year for spooky
new supernatural series whether we're
talking about haunted houses or magical
adventures from high fantasy to horror
and everything in between these are the
TV shows we're looking forward to in
2020 Netflix has so much content that
you're basically never run out of shows
to power through especially when it
comes to genre shows the real problem is
finding the good ones here's a hot tip
for this year's marathon viewing if
you're a fan of supernatural drama then
absolutely check out Spectras it's a new
Brazilian series from writer producer
Douglas Petrie
and if his name sounds familiar you
might just recognize it from two truly
iconic spooky shows Buffy the Vampire
Slayer and American Horror Story coven
on which she served as a writer and
producer the eight episode first season
is set to introduce viewers to the
Liberace district of Sao Paulo Brazil
the home to a large and vibrant Japanese
population because of the blending of
cultures the story which follows five
teenagers as they encountered a
supernatural will be an intriguing mix
of Brazilian folklore and Japanese ghost
stories season one of spec trust is set
to debut on Netflix on February 20th
dispatches from elsewhere the new AMC
series created by Jason Segel looks like
it has the potential to break out of the
narrow confines of genre into something
truly unexpected trailers for the series
frame it as an interesting hybrid of
conspiracy thriller psychedelic
adventure and uplifting journey of
self-discovery there are plenty of
questions begging for answers as the
characters search from a serious woman
named Clara and argue over whether or
not what they're doing is a real quest
or just an elaborate hoax with that in
mind we really don't know how much
fantasy will actually be involved in
this series but we can't wait to find
out with an ensemble cast that includes
Academy Award winner Sally Field Andre
3000 of Outkast Fame and others
dispatches from elsewhere arrives much
first unless you've been hiding out in a
bunker for the past decade or just woke
up from a coma you probably never single
to about The Walking Dead
it's began as a comic book series and
then expanded to television in 2010
where it quickly became one of the
biggest things in the history of cable
TV since then the flagship series and
the franchise has continued his run on
AMC and the spin-off series titled fear
The Walking Dead has enjoyed his own
successful run now in 2020 it's time for
yet another
bündchen in addition to a promise series
of films starring original Walking Dead
hero Rick Grimes The Walking Dead
universe is adding a third series
through its ranks with the Walking Dead
world beyond this new series will take
us to the story of the first generation
of young people who have actually grown
up with the apocalypse
they've come of age in a world of
privilege behind walls that protected
them from the walkers beyond now it's
time for them to venture out into the
hellish landscape for the first time and
we can't wait to see what that looks
like world beyond premieres April 12th
though it reached a climax of sorts of
Avengers and the game in 2019 the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is unloading down
anytime soon we'll be seeing new
characters and old favorites from Marvel
for years to come and the lots of that
is going to be happening on the small
screen that includes plenty of new shows
including the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier and one division arriving on
Disney Plus in the coming months but
even that's not all we'll also be seeing
new interpretations of Marvel heroes
over on Hulu including Hellstrom
hellström is based on the Marvel Comics
characters Damon and say Tana hellström
who in their original forms are
presented as the literal children of
Satan in the new Hulu series Damon and
Ana are cast as a children of a horrific
serial killer who attempt to make amends
for their father's wrongs by hunting
down the worst like humanity has to
offer
much like Doctor Strange before it we
can expect hellström to dig into some of
the more occult heavy corners of the
Marvel Universe and we'll find out
exactly how it does that
on the series lands on Hulu at some
point in 2020 penny dreadful launched in
2014 as a new take on the poll peace and
safety lies fiction from which it
derived its title over the course of
three seasons he was met familiar faces
ranging from the vampire hunting Abraham
Van Helsing to Victor Frankenstein and
his infamous monster or monsters as the
case may be and saw them reinterpreted
in exciting new ways some made for an
addictive horror series now in 2020 the
next chapter and the penny dreadfuls
story begins while the original series
took place in the 1800s and had a very
European feel penny dreadful City of
Angels will move his location to exactly
where the title suggests the new series
is set in Los Angeles during the Golden
Age of Hollywood and because of his
color for new roots it will also pull
heavily from Mexican folklore for its
subject matter viewers can look forward
to plenty of horrific new delights
including demons walking the earth and
the
the conditi Santa Muerte starring
Natalie Dormer of Game of Thrones and
The Hunger Games Fame Daniels avato
Nathan Lane and more penny dreadful City
of Angels arrives on April 26th check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the bail so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]